[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen einen guten
abend und alle sportliche später mit
kristin otto verein fußball guten abend
dieser 8 mai ist ein
geschichtsträchtiger wegen des
internationalen kriegs gedenkens
außerdem wurde im norden gewählt schauen
wir gemeinsam auch die themen
klarer wahlsieg für daniel günther bei
der landtagswahl in schleswig holstein
wird die cdu stärkste kraft
gedenken an das weltkriegs ende vor 77
jahren 1 8 dabei wie kein anderer so
bundeskanzler scholz mit blick auf den
krieg in der ukraine
und jubel in gelsenkirchen schalke 04
kehrt mit dem sieg gegen st pauli nach
nur einem jahr zurück in die erste
fußball-bundesliga
[Musik]
bevor wir zum internationalen weltkriegs
gedenken kommen mit wichtigen reden die
die brücke vom krieg damals zum krieg
heute schlagen erst der blick zur
landtagswahl nach schleswig holstein in
den umfragen hat es sich schon
abgezeichnet und so ist es dann auch
gekommen
cdu-ministerpräsident daniel günther
kann mit einem großen polster wohl
weiter reagieren seine partei hat die
wahl mit deutlichem vorsprung gewonnen
wir lassen uns das jetzt von matthias
fornoff im zdf wahlstudio in kiel ganz
genau zeigen hallo matthias wie sehen
die aktuellsten zahlen jetzt aus hallo
guten abend wir schauen direkt auf die
zweite hochrechnung heute abend punkt 19
uhr und hier kommt sie demnach kommt in
schleswig holstein die cdu auf 42,1
prozent die spd auf 15,6 grüner 18,4
zweitstärkste partei fdp 6,9 afd 4,5
prozent und wäre damit nicht im
parlament und der ssw 6,2 der wäre drin
unter den 6,3 prozent anderen übrigens
auch die linke mit unter zwei prozent
wir schauen mal auf gewinne und verluste
im kieler landtag und da sehen wir ganz
deutliche zugewinne bei der regierenden
cdu noch deutlichere verluste 11,7
punkte bei der spd die grünen gewinnen
dazu 5,5 punkte die fdp verliert 4,6
auch die afg verliert 1,4 und der ssw
kommt mit 2,9 punkt mehr auf sein bestes
ergebnis seit sehr langer zeit was heißt
das für die sitzverteilung im kieler
landtag mit genom and fun 73 sitzen aus
die gab es bisher es können ein paar
mehr noch werden im laufe des abends je
nachdem wie viele direktmandate
die cdu gewinnt die absolute mehrheit
liegt bei 37 die cdu käme auf 34 die spd
auf 13 sitze grüne 15 fdp 6 und ssw fünf
jahren auf jeden fall drin weil die fünf
prozent hürde für sie nicht gilt was
heißt erst fürs regieren hier in
schleswig holstein das ist die
entscheidende linie diese senkrechte
absolute mehrheit 37 sitze da muss man
hin oder über schwarz-grün schafft das
locker schwarz gelb schafft es etwas
knapper aber auch noch recht deutlich
jamaika mit drei parteien natürlich
sowieso cdu mit spd auch dass es satt
möglich und die cdu mit dem
südschleswigschen wählerverband sogar
das hätte eine mehrheit mit anderen
worten die cdu hat hier offensichtlich
die qual der wahl
vielen dank matthias deutlicher
vorsprung also für die cdu die auf jeden
fall weiter regieren wird mit wem ist
daneben die große frage eins steht fest
es war die große popularität von daniel
günther die dazu geführt hat dass es
dieses cdu wahlergebnis gibt er so wie
die anderen spitzenkandidaten sind jetzt
im gespräch in unseren kieler wahlstudio
und zwar mit bettina schausten bitte
bettina so ist es und wir beginnen auch
mit dem wahlsieger dem
cdu-ministerpräsidenten daniel günther
und einer gewissen paradoxie herr
günther sie wollten mit ihrem
regierungsbündnis jamaica weitermachen
nun sind sie dafür zu erfolgreich worauf
stehen die zeichen jetzt schwarz-grün
schwarz-gelb aber erstmal freue ich mich
natürlich darüber dass wir so ein super
ergebnis bekommen haben als cdu so dass
der regierungsauftrag auch klar ist aber
ich habe vorher mal ja immer dafür
geworben jamaika fortzusetzen merkt ihr
auch zwei drittel der wählerinnen und
wähler haben den drei parteien auch ihre
stimme gegeben
und für mich ist vollkommen klar auch in
dieser situation dass wir natürlich auch
mit grünen und fdp ein gespräch jetzt
führen werden das was ich vorher
angekündigt habe geht natürlich auch
nach der wahl so pastors müller
spitzenkandidat der fdp minus 11,7
prozent dramatische verluste haben sich
schon irgend einer analyse einer
erklärung also erstmal herzlichen
glückwunsch und da eine günther das ist
wirklich ein beeindruckender sieg dann
gut da hat es geschafft die seine
popularität auch in stimmen für die cdu
oben zu setzen für uns war von anfang an
klar dass es eine große herausforderung
ist dieser wahlkampf wir sehen gegen
einen der beliebten ministerpräsident
der bundesrepublik angegangen gegen eine
beliebte landesregierung haben uns
selber gleichzeitig neu aufgestellt
personell und auch inhaltlich und dann
ist natürlich der ukraine krieg der viel
aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen hat die
menschen waren sehr besorgt hier auch in
schleswig holstein
das heißt diese konnten mit unseren
themen und auch mit unseren ansätzen
nicht wirklich durchkommen die grünen
spitzenkandidatin und finanzministerin
ist monika heinold und sie wollte hier
eigentlich ministerpräsidentin werden
das hat nicht geklappt aber sie haben
dazugewonnen sind zweiter geworden haben
sie sich heute abend schon beworben bei
daniel günther für eine weitere
koalition also ich habe ihm
selbstverständlich einmal gratuliert und
dieses wahlergebnis zeigt ja dass die
politik der letzten fünf jahre honoriert
wird und es zeigt dass neben der cdu wir
grüne die wahlgewinnerin sind die
menschen in schleswig holstein wollen
eine moderne politik eine politik die
nach vorne geht und deshalb war es sehr
gut dass wir als grüne gesagt haben wir
wollen ganz vorne mitspielen und
deutlich machen wohin die reise gehen
würde und wird wenn wir grüne mit
regierungsverantwortung tragen das
würden wir gerne auch zukünftig machen
jan buchholz der wirtschaftsminister im
lande von der fdp sie wollten 15 prozent
erreichen jetzt 17 was schiefgelaufen im
wahlkampf ja da ist ein
ministerpräsident der ziemlich viele
abgesammelt hat von der zufriedenheit
die grüne und fdp durchaus auch mit frau
gesagt haben im lande das muss man
neidlos anerkennen glückwunsch dazu man
muss aber eben auch sagen ist es jetzt
ja möglich eine regierung auch in der
mitte weiterzuführen dazu stehen wir
bereits haben immer gesagt wir wollen
mit daniel günther weiterregieren andere
wollten wanders weiterregieren jetzt
muss man sehen was daraus wird wir
stehen dafür zur verfügung in der mitte
mitzumachen lars harms der
spitzenkandidat des südschleswigschen
wählerverbands minderheit der dänen und
friesen und freut sich heute abend weil
es ist etwas gelungen was seit glaube
ich seit 1950 nicht gelungen ist ja mal
locker die fünf prozent hürde genommen
die sie gar nicht gebunden sind sie
könnten jetzt eigentlich auch
mitregieren das würde eine mehrheit
tatsächlich ergeben werden sie sich
anbieten rechnerisch ist alles möglich
aber da eine gute ist derjenige der ein
lied oder muss er einladen
selbstverständlich sind wir immer zu
gesprächen bereit das haben wir vorher
gesagt dass wir zu allen gesprächen mit
allen demokratischen parteien bereit
sind das wäre in dem fall natürlich auch
so aber das ist sein job das zu machen
wir freuen uns jetzt erstmal dass wir
tatsächlich das beste ergebnis in der
geschichte es ist wie geholt haben noch
nie hat der ssv 6 prozent bekommt und
das macht uns unheimlich stolz und ich
glaube heute werden wir erst mal nur
damit beschäftigen dass wir richtig
ordentlich feiern
so und letzte frage an den
ministerpräsidenten und wahlsieger kiel
ist heute nächsten sonntag ist
düsseldorf wie viel rückenwind ist das
für ihren cdu-kollegen hendrik wüst
natürlich ist das rückenwind auch für
meinen freund hendrik wüst auch für die
cdu in nordrhein westfalen aber ich
glaube man muss schon sagen es ist eine
landtagswahl hier in schleswig holstein
gewählt gewesen die hier stattgefunden
hat das hat auch was damit zu tun dass
wir eine erfolgreiche regierung haben
ich finde das muss man auch respektieren
ich sage das ausdrücklich hier auch
richtung grüne und auch fdp in der tat
ist die zufriedenheit zu einem großen
teil auch bei uns als cdu gelandet
darüber freue ich mich natürlich aber
klar ist das natürlich ein großartiger
sieg für die cdu und ich glaube das wird
der cdu in nordrhein-westfalen nicht
schaden und vor allem ein wahlerfolg für
für daniel günther der sicherlich jetzt
auch in berlin künftig eine größere
rolle spielen wird und damit geben wir
zurück hier von der kieler förde nach
mainz dankeschön bettina und bis später
der ausgang der schleswig holstein war
natürlich auch spannend auch
aufschlussreich für die bundespolizei
gerade für die cdu die bei den letzten
wahlen ordentlich federn lassen musste
aber natürlich auch für die anderen
parteien erste reaktionen des abends aus
den jeweiligen parteispitzen
ein schönes ergebnis schleswig holstein
hat gewählt und schleswig holstein hat
daniel günther und der cdu das vertrauen
ausgesprochen
schleswig holstein hält kurs und die
wählerinnen und wähler haben das heute
entschieden jetzt ist die fdp auf der
höhe der durchschnittlichen ergebnisse
der letzten jahrzehnte mehr wäre
wünschenswert gewesen aber immerhin dies
wir sehen glaube ich vor allem dass
unsere gute arbeiten der regierung in
den letzten jahren belohnt wurde weil es
ein großes vertrauen gibt es geht heute
abend einen klaren wahlsieger mit deiner
günther auch herzlichen glückwunsch an
ihn es gibt aber mehrere wahlgewinner
genau 2 und das sind eben auch wie grüne
und daraus eine verdammt stolz das
ergebnis für die spd ist bitter und eine
herbe enttäuschung aber die spd im jahr
2022 lässt sich durch rückschläge nicht
mehr verunsichern
wir haben die partei als partei zuletzt
gezeigt wie schnell wir durch
geschlossenheit und durch
entschlossenheit wieder nach vorne
kommen können wir haben uns sicherlich
vorgenommen wieder in den landtag
einzuziehen und der abend ist noch lang
wie man so schön sagt sie haben es
gerade selbst gesagt in der ard zumal
bei 4,9 es hat in hamburg ähnliche züge
gehabt also wir warten mal den abend ab
ich bin noch zuversicht dass wir wieder
hier einziehen soweit also die stimmen
aus der bundespolitik weitere analysen
mehr stimmen und hochrechnungen gibt es
direkt nach dieser heute sendung aus
unserem wahlstudio und jederzeit online
in unserer zdf heute app wir kommen
jetzt zum anderen großen thema der
sendung dem weltkriegs gedenken in einer
zeit in der aktuelle in europa wieder
soldaten und zivilisten sterben und das
heute genau 77 jahre nach dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs mai
1945 rems in frankreich generaloberst
die jodel unterschreibt im
us-hauptquartier die bedingungslose
kapitulation der deutschen wehrmacht sie
tritt in kraft am achten mal die
sowjetunion will aber ihre eigene
zeremonie und darum unterzeichnet
generalfeldmarschall keitel eine weitere
urkunde in berlin karlshorst in der
nacht zum 9
zwei dokumente zwei gedenktage und heute
in berlin erinnerung an die befreiung
vom nationalsozialismus henriette de
maizière
es ist ein gedenken unter dem eindruck
des russischen angriffskrieges in der
ukraine andrej melnitschenko
einen kranz am sowjetischen ehrenmal in
berlin-tiergarten nieder und
bundeskanzler olaf scholz wendet sich
mit einer fernsehansprache an die
menschen darin betont er es sei
geschichtsverfälschung und in form wie
putin den angriffskrieg mit dem kampf
gegen den nationalsozialismus
gleichsetze in der gegenwärtigen lage
kann dies nur bedeuten wir verteidigen
recht und freiheit an der seite der
angegriffenen wir unterstützen die
ukraine im kampf gegen den aggressor
das nicht zu tun hier ist hier zu
kapitulieren vor blanker gewalt und den
aggressor zu bestärkt dieser achte mai
sei wie kein anderer es gehe
buchstäblich um krieg und frieden
aus vielen äußerungen die ich dieser
tage höhere spricht ernste sorge sorge
auch davor dass sich der krieg aus wald
dass der frieden auch bei uns in gefahr
geraten könnte
es wäre falsch das einfach abzutun
solche sorgen müssen ausgesprochen
werden können
gleichzeitig gilt
angst darf uns nicht leben auf dem
bundeskongress des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes in berlin sagt
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
heute dieser krieg sei ein bruch mit
vielem was uns als selbstverständlich
galt es sei ein epochenbruch in diesem
achten mal ist der traum des gemeinsamen
europäischen hauses gescheitert ein
albtraum ist an seine stelle getreten
diese achte mai sein tag des krieges
der tag der befreiung der achte mai ist
heute der 74 tag des krieges gegen die
ukraine ein krieg in europa
gewichtige reden heute die wir uns
einordnen lassen wollen theo koll in
berlin der bundespräsident spricht von
epochenbruch der bundeskanzler davon
dass es einen russischen diktat frieden
nicht geben solle die ukraine und
deutschland würden dies nicht
akzeptieren wie muss man diese worte
einordnen nun beiden als die bisher
klarsten worte richtung putin und beim
kanzler sicher auch als das bemühen das
eigene politische handeln besser zu
erklären und beim bundespräsidenten
insbesondere als er noch viel weiter
gehender warnruf die verurteilung von
putin hätte bei beiden kam deutlicher
ausfallen können da ist von barbarei die
rede und wenn putin von entnazifizierung
spreche dann sei das ein zitat perfider
und zynischer missbrauch der geschichte
gewinnen werde er putin den krieg nicht
so sagte der kanzler es war aber auch
zugleich ein massiver warnruf
insbesondere vom bundespräsidenten der
gleich dreimal vom epochenbruch sprach
viele gewissheiten meinte er unseres
lebens würden hinweggefegt es kämen
gewaltige veränderung auf uns zu die
noch viel tiefer gehen als wir es
aktuell besprechen nicht zuletzt durch
den tiefen einschnitt in die
weltwirtschaft also das war rhetorisch
ein achter mai zwischen zeitenwende und
epochenbruch danke theo koll nach berlin
und die ganze ansprache des
bundeskanzlers die sehen sie bei uns im
zdf um 19 uhr 30 bundestags präsidentin
bärbel bas nahm heute in kiew an
gedenkfeierlichkeiten zum 8 mai teil
traf unter anderem auch ukrainische
präsident seelands geht auch die first
lady jaye beiden kam zu einem
überraschungsbesuch in die ukraine und
gleichzeitig wird und wurde weiter
gekämpft auch heute gab es opfer zu
beklagen tobias häfner viel zu löschen
gibt es nicht mehr für die feuerwehr in
gilo fk in der ost ukraine die frühere
schule völlig zerstört von einem
russischen angriff zwei menschen die
hier eigentlich schutz gesucht hatten
wurden tot geborgen rund 60 werden noch
unter dem schutt vermutet
russland verbindet seine bilder für die
fernsehschirme in der heimat nicht mit
menschlichen tragödien alles seien
präzise gewählte ziele auch das
ukrainische militär veröffentlichte
aufnahmen die hier zeigen offenbar wie
ein russischer hubschrauber auf der
strategisch wichtigen schlangen insel im
schwarzen meer abgeschossen wird
viele ukraine gedenken heute auch des
zweiten weltkriegs und spüren
internationaler unterstützung justins
rudow kanadas premier besuchte bereits
camps zerstört das umland
bärbel bas die bundestagspräsidentin kam
per zug dorthin informierte sich im
zerbombten ihre pin und sagte hilfe zu
mir ist auch wichtig dass sie relativ
schnell für die menschen die
mittlerweile zurückgekommen sind hier in
diese stadt auch insbesondere für die
kinder kindergärten schulen eine
medizinische versorgung bekommen
präsident selen ski bedankte sich für
das votum des bundestags zu
waffenlieferungen erhofft sich aber noch
mehr
ich fordere sie auf uns auch beim thema
eu beitritt zu unterstützen ihr kollege
friedrich merz hat uns da viele
hoffnungen gemacht bei seinem besuch
hier
in vielen familien ist der zweite
weltkrieg heute besonders präsent sie
schauen aufnahmen an in so manch alten
fotoalbum wie bei julia und larissa
shorouk in odessa
aktuell fliegen hier jeden tag raketen
mein vater hat damals gekämpft für einen
friedlichen himmel über uns und nun
lernen unsere kinder aus angst in
dunklen kellern möge gott die angreifer
stoppen sie wollen uns auslöschen das
ist nicht nur krieg hier
aber irgendwann so sagt es die
großmutter tochter und enkelin werde man
hoffentlich einen feiertag für den sieg
in diesem krieg haben
wir sprechen mit katrin eigendorf in
kiew katrin du hattest die gelegenheit
mit der ukrainischen staatsspitze zu
sprechen welche signale gab es da
ja ich hatte die gelegenheit mit
außenminister cholera über das deutsch
ukrainische verhältnisse an diesem tag
heute auch zu sprechen und interessant
ist er hat da sehr in die zukunft
geguckt und hat gesagt das verhältnis
hat sich deutlich verbessert aber die
erwartungen der ukraine an deutschland
als führungs nation und größten staat in
europa sind eben auch extrem hoch und er
sagte wir ukraine sind eben sehr ehrlich
und sehr direkt und wir machen klar was
wir von deutschland erwarten und wir
erwarten von deutschland dass es noch
mehr und deutlicher für die ukraine 1
steht präsident seelands kies antwort
ging in eine ähnliche richtung er sagte
was er erwartet ist dass insgesamt die
europäer doch der ukraine noch viel mehr
vertrauen müssten und darauf setzen
müssten neben dass die ukraine ein
europäischer staat ist also auch in die
zukunft geblickt aber interessant
natürlich dass auch an diesem tag an dem
wichtigen gedenktagen gedenktag an die
opfer des nationalsozialismus des
angriffskriegs auch gegen die ukraine
man vielmehr die opfer im prinzip des
russischen angriffskriegs in den
vordergrund gestellt hat ein besuch auch
von parlamentspräsidentin bars der in
schusssicherer weste stattfand und wo es
darum ging wie kann deutschland an der
seite der ukraine in der zukunft stehen
dankeschön kathrin nach kiew und am 8
mai auch dieses signal die sanktionen
gegen russland sollen nochmals
verschärft werden die führenden
westlichen industrienationen die g7
haben sich darauf geeinigt ein
öl-embargo gegen russland zu verhängen
danach sollen die importe schrittweise
auslaufen
corona dürren und jetzt der krieg das
treibt die lebensmittelpreise massiv in
die höhe entwicklungsministerin schulze
befürchtet dass die größte hungersnot
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg droht mit
millionen toten in der bild am sonntag
sagte sie die lage sei hoch dramatisch
sie forderte keine nahrungsmittel mehr
zu biokraftstoffen zu verarbeiten
der neue csu-generalsekretär martin
huber sieht sich mit plagiatsvorwürfen
konfrontiert die hatte einen experten
der bild am sonntag erhoben allein auf
den ersten seiten der doktorarbeit
fänden sich mehrere zitate ohne oder mit
falscher quellenangabe huber kündigte an
seine dissertation von der
ludwig-maximilians-universität in
münchen überprüfen zu lassen
in der chinesischen
sonderverwaltungszone hongkong wurde ein
neuer regierungschef gewählt
der frühere sicherheitsminister johnny
erhielt von einem peking treuen
wahlkomitee und 99 prozent der stimmen
er war der einzige kandidat
die hatte eine zentrale rolle bei der
niederschlagung der demokratiebewegung
vor drei jahren
jetzt in die usa dort könnte bald das
bundesweite recht auf abtreibung kippen
deshalb sind erneut viele frauen aber
auch männer auf die straße gegangen sie
demonstrierten dafür abtreibungen auch
weiterhin zu erlauben dabei skandierten
sie abtreibung ist ein menschenrecht
anfang der woche war bekanntgeworden
dass der oberste us-gerichtshof das
recht auf eine legale abtreibung
möglicherweise abschaffen will mit einer
endgültigen entscheidung wird in den
nächsten zwei monaten gerechnet
jetzt der sport und christin und ganz
viel jubel beim fußboden ladies first
die frauen des vfl wolfsburg sind zum 17
mal deutscher fußball meister innen
natürlich große freude am vorletzten
spieltag den sie mit einem 10 zu 1
kanter erfolg bei absteiger fc carl
zeiss jena gründen
jubel bei den wolfsburger fußballerinnen
nach dem heutigen schaulaufen gegen jena
sie sind das maß der dinge im deutschen
frauen-fußball erstes tor durch über
peru nach acht minuten den siebten
treffer erzielt nationalstürmerin nach
dem wechsel das zehnte und letzte tor
getan auf das konto von svenja huth zehn
zu eins dann wurde der trainer gejagt
tom ist rot getaucht von alex popp mit
sekt
ich komme doch durchaus nicht drumrum
heute wahrscheinlich von daher lieber
direkt beim ersten mal
sensationell sensationell die saison für
die wolfsburgerinnen folgen soll jetzt
noch der titel im dfb-pokal
im ersten sonntagsspiel bei den männern
trennten sich frankfurt und gladbach
eins zu eins wobei die eintracht einige
profis wegen des europa league finales
geschont hat und kurz vor schluss steht
es bei bayern münchen gegen den vfb
stuttgart 2 2 das wäre ein wichtiger
punkt für den vfb im kampf um den
klassenerhalt aber noch ist es nicht
entschieden mehrere verletzte das ist
die unschöne seite des unbändigen jubel
smit platzsturm bei schalke 04 wieder
aufstieg geschafft die königsblauen
völlig aus dem häuschen
die feier war schon einmal erstklassig
schalke 04 zurück in der ersten liga an
einem abend der an aufstiegs
traumatologie kaum zu überbieten war
voller leistung zu bringen außerdem
zweimal stand jedoch bereits
aussichtslos
erst die 78 minute brachte die erlösung
das siegtor von salat zum 3 2
gleichbedeutend mit der gewissheit die
erstliga abstinenz war nur ein
einjähriges kapitel das tut der
königsblauen seele ebenso gut wie dem
geldbeutel des vereins die finanzlage
nach der trennung von gazprom angespannt
schalke also zum richtigen zeitpunkt
wieder oben dabei und ich hab noch einen
aufsteiger eintracht braunschweig ist ab
kommender saison zweitklassig
kaiserslautern muss in die relegation
gegen dresden viel los filos vielen dank
christian wir schnell und fix auf die
wetter aussichten für morgen die sonne
scheint von einem oft wolkenlosen himmel
nur am alpenrand kann es am nachmittag
auch mal ein gewitter geben die
temperatur steigt auf werte von 17 bis
26 grad
im heute journal um 21.45 interviewt
christian sievers den schleswig
holsteinischen wahlsieger so viel von
uns danke fürs interesse und gerne bis
morgen um sie